new to the trampoline causing a reaction
on financial markets let's have a look
at what happens
uh in currency markets the pound against
the us dollar and what you can see
if you look here as you can see the
pound was getting stronger last week
that's what
hopes of a brexit deal there but then
over the course of the weekend
and into today it felt quite sharply
actually by about three cents at the low
point although it started to bounce back
since then
why is that it's because people are
starting to look at the uk economy
working out how much uk trade could be
affected by this and we can do that
exercise ourselves have a look at the
totality of uk
goods trade this shows you just in
freight units this is the way
they measure that how much trade goes
between the uk and the rest of the world
and what we can do is break it down into
the way that that trade
gets out of the country and comes into
the country you've got two different
ways
that it does that so you've got
container trade so coming in
in containers that's about 43 percent
and then you've got what's called
roll-on roll-off that's basically
goods in lorries going into ferries and
you can see that's the majority
and how much of that might well be
effective well let's look at dover in
particular because it's that dover
calais route
that might well be the epicenter for
this about 17
in total of total uk goods trade could
well be
affected a significant amount although
it's worth saying that's actually come
down
recently if we look specifically at food
trade
uh between the uk and france you can see
it started to drift down this is the
proportion of
food trade that's going to france out of
the eu there is a point though
that at various uh winters it does tend
to peak so the question is whether this
is a bad time of year for it to be
happening if you look back last year
there was a peak there
in december but it's not always uh in
the winter time that it does peak so you
can see in march it's peaked there
uh in june it peaked in 2017 and there
are points where it's in the
december but it's not a given that this
is the very worst time
of year for this to happen that being
said it is worth just taking a step back
and asking this big question about
food security to what extent is the uk
reliant on the rest of the world
for its food supply well this chart kind
of tells you that story the higher this
is the more of our food we source
domestically and you can see
actually since the 1950s it's gone up
it's higher now than it was back in the
50s
and the 60s but it has fallen a bit
since the 1980s this shot
a big part of that story both about
what's going on with covet 19 and these
restrictions
but also about brexit how much we rely
on the rest of the world
for our food